put a finger down if you've ever had to
teach your child how not to get killed
by the police
any fingers left that's privilege
stephen twitch boss and alison hulker
use tick tock to share a powerful
message
check your privilege edition that's the
couple with their four-year-old son
maddox participating in a tick-tock
challenge called
check your privilege which asks users a
series of questions about their life
experiences
for each one that applies to you you put
a finger down
allison posted the video to her account
and wrote in text on screen
white privilege is real put a finger
down if you have been called a racial
slur
put a finger down if you've been
followed in a store unnecessarily
put a finger down if someone has crossed
the street to avoid passing you
and there's more put a finger down if
you've had someone clinch their purse in
an elevator with you
put a finger down if you've had someone
step off of an elevator to keep from
riding with you put a finger down if
you've been accused of not being able to
afford something expensive
the so you think you can dance alums
tick tock video comes after
george floyd a 46 year old black man in
minneapolis
died when a police officer pressed his
knee into his neck
for more than eight minutes his death
has sparked protests against police
brutality
across the nation and the world put a
finger down if you have had fear in your
heart when
being stopped by the police put a finger
down if you have never been given a pass
on a citation that you deserved
put a finger down if you have been
stopped or detained by police for no
valid reason
twitch ran out of fingers quickly as for
alison she still had
all 10 fingers up until the very end put
a finger down if you've ever had to
teach your child how not to get killed
by the police
any fingers left that's privilege
but alison and twitch aren't the only
stars speaking out
we need justice for george floyd we all
witness his murder in broad daylight
we're broken and we're disgusted we
cannot normalize this pain
beyonce took to instagram to call for
action
yes someone's been charged but justice
is far from being achieved
please sign the petition and continue to
pray for peace compassion
and healing for our country billy eilish
used her platform to slam the all lives
matter movement
that's been used to invalidate the black
lives matter campaign
in the post she wrote this is not about
you stop making
everything about you you are not in need
you are not
in danger adding society gives you
privilege
just for being white kevin hart opened
up about the protests on
instagram we're not talking about why
we're witnessing what we're witnessing
there's a reason
and i don't want to lose sight of that
reason that reason is because another
man died at the hands of a police
officer
so did lizzo not only do we want to see
appropriate justice indictments
convictions
we want to see the entire police
organization
renovated we need a whole
investigation cardi b shared her outrage
over police brutality on twitter i feel
like i've done videos
against police brutality brutality i
feel like this is like my seventh time
people are tired of that
when it caught up with kelly rowland
last week she opened up about feeling
hurt and anger over the racial injustice
in the u.s
i can't do still
i'm angry i'm hurt
um at times feeling hopeless
but then sometimes like i look at my son
and i'm like hell no i gotta keep going
and what do i need to do
um feeling for
the families that have to go through all
this
communities all their emotions
just makes me angry there's so many
things i'm feeling like everyone else
but
kelly said it gives her hope to see
people rallying around the cause
i'm happy that it's actually bothering
us
to the way it is now because that's when
action happens
we have to be collected and unified this
is
years upon years of oppression and
depression and it's so
deeply rooted and
that's why it's just we're having a
tough time with all this is so much
trauma
even watching it every day is trauma
what is this gonna do to us in 10 years
we're watching it how can you not be
appalled
even if you're not black you should be
appalled if you're not black you should
be moving